It's time to clear this desktop if we don't do this your creative growth is in jeopardy
Wow
For years rent has been working up with an janky old door desk
He's got all these really cool props and gadgets and things like that, that he needs, that he likes to keep on his desk
But I really just cannot stand the cable management; the way that it's a door
That's propped up on metal pieces really gets to me going to make the ultimate
Wrender-ised desk a modded desk built specifically for Wren
I'm warming up to the idea, but it's just gonna. It's gonna take a minute because I gotta clean all this stuff up
That was easy
But what Jake is annoyed by flagrant use of... yes?
Let's put a light yes for the extra light. Can't wrap his mind around right. It's this these things here
My desk is C clamped to legs
The legs are the C clamp yep, yeah, yeah, this is where our clamps went he's in love with this thing
I mean everything from the history of it, to the work that he's already put into it, to the man-hours
Just spent making cool stuff on this surface, so we're gonna preserve that you might remember last year
I built him this huge electric skateboard
That was super fun
And he likes to ride one wheel all the time we're gonna incorporate
both a place for the electric skateboard and a place for the one wheel in here in addition Bren has a
Three monitor setup and is often working off of two computers
so there's gonna be plenty of room for that plenty of room for building plenty room for gadgets, and we're gonna maintain the
historical sentimental significance of this here desk
I'll stain it all I'll get a fresh stain and a fresh coat of varnish and finish
So it will all look like it's one piece and the first thing that I have to do is sand it all down
We try let me put on my hat, what do you guys think of this hat do you like it because if you do
We'll sell it. It's not out yet. Don't go running off to the store
Just yet anyway, that's not what I'm here to talk about. I'm here to talk about Friday's video. We're shooting a video gonna involve
Adrian it's gonna involve Nikko
It's gonna involve our friend Freddie coming off of the rock production
Adrian and Nikko wanted to do something that was a little bit more fun a little bit more humorous
So they came up with this ridiculous idea about how there's two cops in a fight
They need to do the most ridiculous extreme reloads to take out all the bad guys
it's very important that both Nikko and
Adrian work together to come up with the best way to shoot those sequences because that's gonna make the whole
Piece hit home. They are unable to work together on this it's gonna make the video fall flat
There's a girl tied up like Freddy standing there. He's like you only have five seconds so coming
On the door I'm trying to do the ropes in the person the children like
Talked himself in like some dudes come in
Bang bang bang Freddy's gun locks back
Empty and pretty girls
Or like does that me like this is go up and lengthen I?
Shoot a guy at the hostage just
Like he's into that more guys come running in we fight those guys and just I'm afraid. He's empty. He doesn't like a fancy yellow
So that's how it's gonna be like an elevating game of course where we're on the same side
instead of pose neck school
Today for shot I would have be a shot that sets up the pressures
Banging on the door so the goons are even closer even more present then the second shot
I would have be the first character introduction
Which probably mean about me you see who you're dealing with you see that but gun obviously I'm nervous you see I'm sweating
See I'm a cop close, but I feel like the first the very opening shot
We need to do something that hooks them like that's super cool, so I was imagining you sliding into frame
And then you finishing like two guys for already in there and Bernie's already you know reloading
maybe you know ice for the first the first opening to be like as if you're coming into the
Action sequence and you've missed like the first half
We are now entering phase 2 of Ren's epic desk build and today
We're gonna pick up some hardware so that we can fit the world's largest electric skateboard on the front of it
I'm gonna put the board itself like at an angle an angle in there the thing is that how wide is the board I'd have
to go to
It I'm going into a desk that I made out of doors
gotcha
All right you remember how I was worried about the sides of the best being a little wobbly
Yeah, well that isn't a problem whatsoever at all keep that off of a boat
Dude, this thing's got great bones check it check this out feel how solid this is oh
Wow, this is so sturdy. Oh, don't don't like jump on it with all your force desk, Brenda
Is that this is the bones all right
Let's move it up, right
And I want to talk about
What is viewing it next because I realized something. There is no chance of this desk looking pretty I
Trusted you Jake, but don't worry Ren you're pretty enough to make up for the ugly desk, and we're gonna go straight for function, okay
crazy kids we're gonna rename the title of this video to the
Ren's
Extremely functional desk mod. It has all look at all this room in the middle
I eliminated the problem of sink in the middle by adding the support beam great. You know how used to bow in the middle yeah
It's a problem of the past my friend cool your knees. I'm gonna hit it you're gonna be fine
I'm gonna run just for you surge protectors
You only need to deal with two outlets at the base of the desk?
So you're so it's gonna be super easy to take
Things on and off your desk without having to fumble around on the ground mess with cables and then up here
Underneath right here will be our cable management. It's gonna be sick. Dude. How I?
Originally embrace the fact that the electric skateboard the world's largest electric skateboard was going to be ugly and not functional for time it became
Beautiful and functional we're doing the opposite here. Okay. It's becoming more functional, but the more function we have the less
Beauty we have you can see that electric skateboard video, just link below Jake when you started this you promised me
It would look pretty you pinky promised it would look pretty
beautiful
Beauty is in the eye of the beholder my friend
I don't want to tell you because I did not break my promise it's gonna be so functional
It's gonna be a thing of beauty remember those days when he used to shoot like the Stevens moves your friends
That was cool like this is it yeah
No, just like take a second. Okay. Who's looking? Where is he getting the bags from the dead body whoops it?
Here yes walking like no weights turn around and like I agree have a bag yeah
And I like been
Like come on I end up with both making he has a gun, and I'm just going like
He read out the reloads which is the most challenging part of this I've broken down like action into
Bite-sized chunks so many times now that like that's not really it's hard for me, but the creative aspect of this stuff
It's really the true challenge, which is that's where my crazy reload. How does Freddie heaven even crazier reload?
What can he do that?
Special when we have the guys of rifle and he run up to him and we try to reload his right from what can we?
Do with him that special like or another great examples when Freddie and I start struggling over the gun
like doing the whole like trying to jam the Megan and like constantly blocking and dodging like that's
Getting creative in the moment and that stuff's really important to come up with
In concrete
Oh
Snap you're drilling through that one drill through that one the desk. This is Ren's highly functional desk. Mud you ready
That is scary house dumb usually hole out of a drill but these arrived
Protection I
Don't know. I haven't totally onto it
I was focused more on how it was drilling that I was on the drill itself. Well kid you made the sizzle
So the key to a good cut is that you do from both sides and hang on hang on
Don't look don't look get ready Ren's highly functional despot is now complete ready. You could join me a
Giant skateboard as the back of your desk is like the coolest thing
I will actually you know when you store it the other way because the walkway to the camera room is right here
But just for the looks. I have the wheels what do you need to start the other way but?
My favorite features, okay
You like to pull in in the morning on your one wheel well guess what got that charger ready for you right there alright?
That's my kind of parking spot pretty nifty. That's super nifty
You got power strip here and powered ship here
I'm gonna replace that green hey, it's still industrial, and you don't have to worry about keeping it nice. You can just
Do whatever you got to do desk is complete? I think it turned out wonderfully
Let me show you guys what I did first and foremost rented like a smooth surface here on the top
So I just sanded everything down really nicely after I found out that the stain
Wasn't really gonna take I wanted to go for just the complete industrial look
And I think that really comes through with the sanding that I did here
I was also able to preserve the Omega symbol
Which is one of the things that Renton liked about the desk I decided not to replace this monitor stand because well
It was well
Built and it was working fine next thing that I did I used
Carmichael's old door desk to make the actual feet of the desk itself
Now when I first bought those on there was a little wobbly
So I went ahead and I put brackets here to help stabilize the legs in addition
I included a large
Cross beam that goes from one leg to the other does a couple things number one it
Stabilizes the sides and then number two it prevents the desk from bowing when there's a lot of weight in the middle
I included an electrical hole here for the one-wheel charger included two
Different surge protectors one on each side of the desk now in order to make it as simple as possible
I connected the surge protectors together, which I know is kind of a surge protector fro faux pas
But we're running surge protectors into a battery protector which goes into a closed circuit
So I think it's gonna be just fine now
He only has to worry about
Unplugging one cable when he wants to move to death then obviously I included hooks for the electric skateboard
Which makes it real easy to take off and put back on so you can actually use it however much you want
included monitor holes here
Which go straight down and then over to either sides to connect any electric hole that you have on top here so anyway
I think we made great use of parts that we already had here. We made the thing more sturdy. It's way more efficient
It's built for what rent actually does rather than using the old C clamps that we were using previously which obviously were super janky
The point of the giant board is that this desk could in theory
When the point of the joint
Is that?
Wren just loves his Electric skateboards to channel some super huge wall Jake built in the world's biggest
Let's go get to work Andrew yes, we've important things to do I can't be distracted by this fascinating desk apparatus
Pitch deck is done. Yes
What beast please
You don't know I think the worst thing into the Internet's doing people right now
It's leading everybody to believe that everybody else is an idiot especially people that disagree with them
Everybody's first reaction is somebody that disagrees with them. It's like. Oh you're an idiot
It's like actually the vast majority of people aren't idiots
They just either are coming from a different background having a belief system have different reasons have different like whole variety of things
assuming that somebody else they may be it especially when they're professional in their field is like the worst mistake one person can make if
Every stops just Amelie claiming every else's an idiot. I think the world to be a better place
Eliza now picks which songs she likes to listen to on YouTube in which he doesn't like a song she doesn't know
Fine and I flipped the song
Fine